new york governor andrew cuomo's
decision to resign stepping down two
weeks before legislators can launch
impeachment proceedings on multiple
cases of alleged wrongdoing the
three-term democrat faced growing
pressure to quit after that bombshell
report detailing sexual harassment
allegations from 11 different women now
cuomo insists he did not harass or grope
anyone at least by his definition and he
says he's resigning because it's best
for the state of new york lieutenant
governor kathy hokel will now become the
state's first female governor think
about that cuomo announced his
resignation one day after our national
correspondent jerica duncan's exclusive
interview with one of cuomo's accusers
andrika joins us now once again jerika
good morning to you good morning tony
you know at the height of the pandemic
cuomo was one of the most popular
politicians in the country but his fall
from grace has been swift despite his
resignation he calls the sexual
harassment allegations unfair and untrue
and believes they are politically
motivated
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing a somber governor
andrew cuomo spoke directly to the
camera apologizing if he ever made
anyone uncomfortable but continuing to
deny the sexual harassment allegations
in my mind
i've never crossed the line with anyone
but
i didn't realize the extent to which the
line has been redrawn his resignation
came eight days after the state attorney
general's office released a scathing
report documenting sexual harassment
allegations from 11 women one of them a
state trooper on his protective detail
for the first time he addressed her
allegations the trooper also said that
in an elevator i touched her back
and when i was walking past her
in a doorway i touched her stomach
now i don't recall doing it
but if she said i did it
i believe her among the most serious
allegations in the report were from a
woman identified as executive assistant
number one brittany commisso she spoke
exclusively to us and albany's times
union newspaper after the report's
release when he put his hand up my
blouse and cupped my breast over my bra
commisso told us cuomo also gave her
intimate hugs kissed her on the cheek
and once on the lips and touched her
bottom there was a time when it between
my personal life and this it was too
much
people don't understand lindsey boylan
one of his accusers reacted to cuomo's
resignation by tweeting from the
beginning i simply asked that the
governor stop his abusive behavior she
thanked those who have pursued the truth
an attorney for accuser charlotte
bennett said the governor's decision to
resign is quote not the end of our
reckoning with sexual harassment but it
is an important step in the right
direction while the embattled governor
will no longer fight to stay in office
he will continue to fight the
allegations his personal attorney rita
glavin this hasn't been
and it's not going to be a fair process
and in fact the governor has been given
no process
we spoke to commisso by text after the
governor's
resignation and she said she was
speechless and found the attorney's
press conference that happened
beforehand offensive the governor's
legal battle might not be over he faces
possible civil suits and criminal
charges the albany district attorney's
office continues to investigate
commisso's allegations and i know when
we were sitting here yesterday for that
special report it was shocking because i
think we both were prepared based on
that press conference with the attorney
for a fight right but instead he said
you know he wasn't interested in doing
that anymore and to the point some of
the women who have accused him of this
misconduct said they felt re-victimized
in it there is a split between them and
he may live to fight another day because
he's saying i you know there's a
politically motivated report but at the
same time although i don't think i did
anything wrong i understand that the
country has moved in a different
direction and maybe the line was redrawn
eureka is always stellar reporting
appreciate you thank you